police have identified the suicide
bomber and an ariana grande concert in
Manchester England you can hear the bomb
go off and see the panic unfold in video
taken from inside the Manchester Arena
[Applause]
the explosion happened at the end of
last night's concert thousands of young
people scrambled to get away from the
scene Isis now claimed responsibility
for what the British prime minister
calls a callous terrorist attack and
we're starting to learn more about the
people who were killed teenager Georgina
Calendar was a big fan of ariana grande
she took pictures with the pop star two
years ago and eight-year-old Saffy
Rousseau's was the youngest known victim
her primary teacher described her as
quiet and unassuming with the creative
flair a total of 22 people died in
Britain's worst terror attacks since the
2005 transit attacks in London 59 others
have been wounded
police say the lone bomber was also
killed in this horrible attack CBS
Evening News anchor Scott Pelley has
just arrived in Manchester he has a very
latest
Scott good morning what can you tell us
Gail were just short of the arena right
here just beyond that blue crane is
where the bombing occurred the police
are telling us this morning that it was
a suicide bombing and that the man who
carried out that bombing was Salman
Abadi a 23 year old man that the police
say they knew and had concerns about
before all of this happened another 23
year old man was arrested in Manchester
but they say that that is related to
this case we're not sure how it is
related but the police are telling us
that Abdi apparently acted alone in the
bombing last night this morning Isis has
claimed responsibility saying that one
of its so-called soldiers carried out
the bombing it called the victims of the
bombing Crusaders but of course we know
this morning that they were mostly girls
mostly teenagers Mark Phillips has been
following the investigation from the
beginning and joins us right now mark
it's got the shock over this attack is
not just to do with the numbers of
people killed it has to do with their
age these were as you say kids teenagers
some kids still in primary school many
of whom now will
hold the concert was a sellout and was
just ending the last song sung the young
happy crowd was beginning to file out of
the arena a dashcam in the parking lot
caught the blast the crowd began to
panic the bomber was not in the arena he
had come to the concert on the local
rail system and had approached one of
the main exits as the audience was
making its way out some meeting parents
well the lights came out after the
concert and everyone was getting up to
leave and all of a sudden there was a
big foul
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this has been the most horrific incident
we have ever faced here in Greater
Manchester Manchester police chief Ian
Hopkins says there are many young people
among the victims we believe the
attacker was carrying an improvised
explosive device which he detonated
causing this atrocity the bomb was
designed to kill and maim many of the
survivors suffered shrapnel wounds there
had been security at the concert but the
bomber did not apparently attempt to get
in his victims came to him that a good
evening until then this morning concert
goers were wandering the streets of
Manchester many still unable to make
sense of what had happened you wouldn't
think something that would happen to you
yeah and then when it happens to you
it's just so like unreal you don't
it really hits you Britain's Prime
Minister Theresa May expressed her
country's horror and resolved all acts
of terrorism are cowardly attacks on
innocent people but this attack stands
out for its appalling sickening
cowardice deliberately targeting
innocent defenseless children and young
people who should have been enjoying one
of the most memorable nights of their
lives
a massive counterterrorism operation is
now under way here we understand the
police have made in fact a number of
arrests as they tried to determine
whether Solomon Abadie was in fact a
lone wolf or had helped mark Phillips
thanks very much